a salute of defiance
after being locked out of his own
embassy
myanmar's man in london facing the
consequences
of defying the military regime at home
sky news what's your message to the uk
now this is happening uh you know that
you know this kind of good is
happening uh in the middle of uk
and uh middle east london so
it shouldn't be a happen what would you
like them to do what do you want the uk
to do
move on he's referring to embassy
officials
who've taken charge of the mission cures
forced to spend wednesday night in his
car
before seeking help from the foreign
office in an extraordinary standoff
will you return home if they don't
support you
do you want me to you see get killing
you think he'll be killed if you go home
who knows what have you been threatened
with that kind of
retaliation
okay next next one next one
he's every reason to be scared hundreds
of people
including children have been killed by
government forces
in myanmar during weeks of protests
after the military
seized control the uk has condemned the
coup
but this mini regime change at the
myanmar embassy
poses a diplomatic dilemma the british
government has to deal with governments
and so they have to have
ambassadors in london representing their
governments
if this poor gentleman is no longer
representing the myanmar government then
effectively
he becomes a dissident and he might have
to apply for asylum if he wants to stay
in this country
[Applause]
the ambassador's supporters want the uk
to back their man
and help oust the military junta
tributes
to those who've died a reminder of
what's at stake
debra haynes sky news